ces dons ce champ à l'abri des regards
cap des lois et blabla ni 30 ans s'est
immolé par le feu en novembre dernier il
ne recevait plus des dalles emploi
depuis deux ans pour hamouda son voisin
son acte et celui du désespoir
en tunisie les immolations n'ont pas
cessé depuis la révolution de 2011 mais
elles sont peu médiatisé pour éviter
l'effet de contagion des gestes
désespérés en réaction à des situations
d'extrême précarité
aujourd'hui les immolations touche
toutes les régions sans qu'il n'y ait de
chiffres officiels en 2017 une
immolation dans la ville de sidi bouzid
qui avait déclenché la vague des
printemps arabes